So now let's talk about Shepard Smith on Fox
news because we act [inaudible] what's going
on with Trump and Ukraine is so crazy.
It's so out there in terms of the, the seriousness
and the brazen nature of it that not one,
but multiple Fox news hosts have been trying
to insert some dose of reality into coverage
of the story.
So we already talked about a Fox host John
Roberts confronting Rudy Giuliani on the Fox
Sunday program.
Uh, that was great to some degree that it
potentially pierced the echo chamber of some
of the Fox news audience.
This was not the only time that the Trump
Ukraine story was called out.
Shepard Smith tried merely telling the truth,
pointing out that the issue here is not Biden.
It's Trump's phone call, which we now know
was proceeded by a few days with Trump's order
that hundreds of millions of dollars in military
aid to Ukraine be withheld.
And Shepard Smith tells it like it is.
There's no evidence that the allegations against
Joe Biden have anything to them.
No facts support the allegation that Biden
did anything wrong here, really pure seeing
the narrative of the average Fox news viewer.
Take a look.
They failed where the Russia, they failed
with recession, they failed with everything
and now they're bringing this up to one who's
got the problem is biting cause you look at
what Biden did, Biden did what they would
like to have me do except that one problem
I didn't do it.
There is known, known evidence that Biden
did anything wrong.
The whole thing involved corruption in Ukraine,
a corrupt prosecutor who much of the world
was pressuring Ukraine to remove earlier this
year over Ukrainian officials said there was
no evidence of any wrongdoing by Joe Biden
or his son Hunter.
The real issue here is the phone call, the
claim that the president pressure to foreign
leader to investigate a political rival and
the failure to pass the whistle whistleblower
complaint to Congress.
Now among Democrats, pressure to impeach this
president is building
Shep speaking clearly, accurately and truthfully.
This is not a Pat on the back to ship.
This is what every news reporters should be
doing.
This is what we would expect on every network.
Simply saying, here is what we know happened.
Here's what Trump is alleging and there is
no evidence for what Donald Trump is alleging
here.
Now, fascinatingly, Shep Smith is not on Fox
news at 3:00 AM he has like a normal daytime
newscast.
Now that being said, the middle of the afternoon
Eastern time is not exactly the hot time to
be doing news, but Shep is telling it like
it is at least on some issues and every time
that this happens I get emails from people
in my audience saying, David Shep has no place
at Fox.
He should really be elsewhere.
And again, I've said before, Shep is not going
to take down the broader narrative of Fox
news as a tool of the Republican party, but
simply being there and getting to tell the
truth every once in awhile, Shep is invading
the otherwise unfettered Trumpy and narrative
that the Fox news audience is generally speaking
used to.
And that's a good thing.
And I was looking at some of the comments
online from the Fox news audience about this
segment, and you see the normal stuff about
no one cares what you think.
Mrs. Smith, I saw a referring to Shep Smith,
or no one likes this afeminant outburst, stuff
like that, homophobic stuff about Shep Smith.
Everything that you would expect.
I still think that there is some good done
by Shep Smith presence on Fox news, even though
it also potentially, as I've said before,
does provide some cover to Fox to say we've
got some conservative editorial stuff going
on, but our news is right down the middle
and pointing to Shep Smith, which is of course
a total distortion of the overall balance
of what we're getting on Fox news.
Let me know what you think.
Let me know what you think about Shep's presence
on the channel.